he's so lucky he's his most popular
characters are balls characters have
hair but glass Professor Xavier can
easily show up and be like look all
three of you need
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey Andrew it's 953 p.m. right now
and we are here because we heard the
Dark Phoenix trailer is dropping thanks
for coming here last minute Andrea for
x-men Dark Phoenix is one of three
graphic novels I read this year
unfortunately I read it many months ago
when the first pictures drop because I
thought that's what we were getting a
trailer hurry this now I only remember
bits and pieces Oh beginning middle and
end but before this trailer begins
here's a photo on screen if there's one
line that I think would be the perfect
tease for this movie or just a really
cool scene I want does the only thing I
ask from the group is this picture with
Xavier
going Andrew you want to take this one
POW without restraint knowledge without
wisdom age without maturity passion
without love I must fight Eugene and
Jesus Christ together active I must I
will win I guarantee James McAvoy's a
little better John right and I got a lot
of other things that I hope for this
movie and the thing is - I know it's
probably not gonna even be at all
resembling here we've got a lot
hey it's a passion really quick today
John and I both noticed like as so many
people have been coming over to our
patreon I'm really really grateful
everyone who's been coming by like it's
been it's been a really touching
experience
so yeah we do TV show reactions in
weekly q and A's and would love for you
to come check us out anyway guys you
ready to watch this thing we all have
opinions already you look kind of weird
then take Sunday the slightest tap to
tip it in the wrong direction
and the charms I had to keep a stable
I'm protected like real Jean Grae origin
[Music]
in this discussion came looking for
answers you feel like you don't belong
here
[Music]
they can't begin to comprehend what you
are she's changing
public didn't come here looking for
answers you came here looking 15 issue
[Music]
yeah I'm digging this guy
[Music]
jeet lost before but she still our
friend this is your pork chops on the
break
I'm sorry as in something similar you're
always sorry Charles and there's always
a speech
[Music]
don't do
they're raised it looks like a comic
this looks like a comic okay
[Music]
that's where I want to go on Valentine's
Day right right there yeah it's like a
heart pumping good time full of love and
romance what I really love about it even
though it's a Jean Grey story it feels
like an x-men comic book you know feels
like it's cartoon in overall opinion I
really do think that this has a
different look it's kind of cool that
Simon Kinberg the guy's been an active
producer and writer on this is now
behind the camera here I see a more
authentic comic book inspiration is what
it's basically what I'm getting in terms
of like the tone and the style and the
look back for sure I mean I got similar
like excitement vibes that I got from
like the first class trailer back in the
day yeah and some of the vibes of like
just the filmmaking aesthetics of the
original x-men movies because this just
felt more like a film than like a roller
coaster it looked like maybe they're
trying to split the difference between
the more grounded you know cinematic
Logan esque style but with the x-men
trappings yeah it still has a grounded
feeling to it in certain ways obviously
you know when you see the music mutant
powers that takes a little bit of the
grandness away but again just in tone
but from the footage we're seeing and
also just from the title of the film
obviously you know this movie is very
heavily influenced by the Dark Phoenix s
storyline which was written in 1980 by
Chris Claremont and what happens in that
story line is you know Jean Grey is
exposed to the deadly radiation of a
solar flare and she merges with the
Phoenix and the Phoenix is basically the
immortal manifestation of the universal
force of life and power and when she
gets the N she when she merges she
becomes the Dark Phoenix and her power
level is just incredible when she
becomes the dark beings like she still
retains the ability to use telekinesis
and telepathy but a much higher and
stronger levels now when she's the Dark
Phoenix she can also fly at supersonic
speeds and she can also rearrange the
molecular structure of matter now what
happens in the comics Professor Xavier
liked to try and control and that
controller but to keep her more like
going dark a NEMA and crazy and to keep
her more on the fence rather you know
from using her powers in the wrong way
he kind of builds psychic circuit
breakers in her mind but just over time
it just becomes less and less effective
and I think they're they're kind of
utilizing that one of
in Australia because that's a very
important entity to me just that
relationship between Professor Xavier
and Jean Grey and what regardless of
what you think of x-men apocalypse or
Sophie Turner's performance as Jean Grey
and I thought one thing I thought that
movie kneeled was their chemistry in
their relationship and I found myself
giving a [ __ ] and really being
emotionally invested in those characters
and just really being interested in like
how much more this relationship is gonna
evolve to what I don't want to see
happen even though it's gonna be
incredible just I'm really hoping they
utilize the psychic circuit breakers
portion because obviously it looks like
he fails in what he's trying to do to
keep her mind at bay or controller to
protect just obviously we see later in
the trailer where beast is blaming
Charles for you know her going you know
Dark Phoenix on them she kind of seemed
like she was playing the Wolverine part
right loosen those will you cage the
Beast the Beast gets angry you have no
idea you have no idea I was expecting
this to feel completely different from
the comic and it certainly does what I
really love about this too is that after
having Apocalypse this feels really
personal it feels like it everything
involved is about the characters it's
not just about there's a big threat out
there that's endangering mutants when it
seems like there's something at stake
for each character involved yeah Dark
Phoenix is such a threat but they can't
just kill her because it's Jean other
thing that I'm really looking forward to
this movie is the psychological level of
what they're all dealing with and going
through life again as you just pointed
out it's someone that's close to them
and you know then when they're playing
the blame game I like that kind of human
drama and emotion like that that's when
I get really invested and I find that
stuff interesting so you can count on
Michael Fassbender for that one you know
he's doing all the usual magneto Faust
meander stuff nobody can ds3 me he's
crying he's my favorite thing like you
know the main takeaway I got from this
trailer was like x-men to me has always
occupied its own Lane kind of as a
superhero franchise and apocalypse kind
of overstep that line for me so to come
back to this I'm like cool this looks
unique it looks like its own thing yeah
has the potential to be both a
satisfying comic book movie and a film I
do completely agree with you because I
just wasn't sure what the direction of
this movie would be you know with all
the news about reshoots and retooling
seeing the direction of the movie
because I don't know like is this gonna
be like sophie turner the movie yeah
how's Ian Sam we're gonna feel in here I
like how it actually feels really
contained like there was this little
snippets of moments that reminded me of
the show towards the end of the trailer
when they're in costume and they're in a
neighborhood yeah like they're with the
people who they're gonna protect the
people in the neighborhood I heard
Jessica Chastain was in this I was like
okay she's gonna be like the real
villain of the movie with this start
Phoenix is the threat yeah that's what
we're wrong with x-men 3 it was like
there's a bunch of [ __ ] going on and
there's a thing going on to who you know
that should be the main focus
yeah and this and it feels like no this
whole thing is about Dark Phoenix and
that's what got me most excited yeah
that's a good point I had a feeling I
would like the trailer but I'm more like
this feels like the x-men movies I that
I love apocalypse was like those cool
but this was like this is the kind of
personal x-men tale that I love and I'm
halfway through I was like and Deadpool
could just show up yeah this whole thing
go they actually when they have the line
of them in the suit in the suits in the
neighborhood for a second I was like
Exeter looks like she's giving a pretty
emotionally invested performance and we
don't get any scenes from her but like
one of my big concerns was just I didn't
get a huge impression from her in
Apocalypse yeah there's a lot that rides
on her for this and she has a chance now
to you know make a mark on this nice
it's all on Jennifer Lawrence Oh
Jennifer Lucas at the truth anti share
an element that I've been hoping for and
I feel like there's a you could do it
with this movie is to enhance Cyclops
and and to have them being a
relationship because that's that was
such a big element of the comic that I
really gravitated towards I didn't
really get a huge impression I guess
that kind of concerns me cuz I would
like to see them enhanced Cyclops it
makes sense to have so many similarities
three because part of x-men 3
doing kind of watered down version of
this storyline and so yeah I'm a little
alarmed that we don't see much of
cyclops that's significant because that
kind of says to me that he's probably
gonna be an afterthought again they seem
like they could equally be pedestrian or
perhaps important I just can't tell
which like that scene where he's got his
hand on her face I'm like that could be
a very intimate touching moment because
maybe their romantic chemistry you know
is very palpable or it could be kind of
like the earlier scene where he's like
the she's - she's our friend
we got a hug yeah you know I gotta say
one thing criticism but really like they
age from the 60s to the 90s when you see
them now at night it doesn't like
they're thirty or forty years older than
when we saw them in first class if
there's one thing the x-men films have
always been tremendous at its the cold
sorry guys my bad I get skeptical to
would sigh again Simon Kinberg he's been
in the business for a long time he's
produced every x-men film he's seen
what's worked he's seen what's not work
but he's never directed anything ever
it's just again I'm not saying the films
not gonna be good or great but it just
leaves a little bit of The Skeptical set
reasons that come in with apprehension
yeah even though it's a Jean Grey story
it feels like an x-men comic book you
know it feels like a cartoon what I was
most impressed by it feels like everyone
has an emotional stake in this movie
because they all all the characters are
coming - if everyone knows Jean they've
developed a relationship with her
they've been through experiences the
Cyclops stuff looks like it could
potentially work even like the mystique
stuff you know as much as I like to join
the clown on Jennifer Lawrence game in
terms of like some fun conversation once
in a while every time I watch her I'm
never like this is like anything I could
bring up a concern about I can also see
how it might go great yeah there's
nothing that says a hundred percent like
I don't think that's gonna be I feel
like this could really work I love this
like emotional story of professional
professor Eck's like what you were
talking about - I like how Magneto's
trying to control Phoenix you know like
x-men 3 I think you said it best - I
just look up personal yeah alright guys
what do you think of the Dark Phoenix
trailer do you think stuff looks good in
the movie let me know I want to see it
the ultimate question is to ask you you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
hey click that notification about the
subscribe buttons don't mean anything
anymore
well they do the help they just don't
give you the videos andrew gordon movie
source channel go follow him patreon is
a website that exists for many a creator
or find your favorite creator and go
support them beautiful yeah good night
everybody
and yeah I have faith in this movie I've
been up since 5 a.m.